last year here at comic-con we had an
unexpected guest drop in on us it did
not go well I'll be honest he was booed
off the stage now he has demanded to
come back and visit again this year he's
flown in directly from his top secret
lair in golf club and mar-a-lago please
welcome captain make America great again
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone psyche you coded and and
please please please
correction I am now no longer captain
make America great again I am president
captain
Wow Wow listen to those Woo's they're
going back sir I got to be honest with
you I don't think those are Woo's oh
sure they are that's how these nerds
cheer I have had the greatest year of
any superhero in the history of
superheroes ever hashtag ever okay well
you know what's happening you know
what's having an even bigger year Wonder
Woman
Thursday excuse me I do not want to talk
about crooked
Wonder Woman go all right she is a
low-energy
what are you talking about what do you
talking about she has a number one
superhero movie this year what do you
talk about please like I have proof
there is widespread viewer Freud that
sounds like one of your crazy conspiracy
theories I don't like her all right she
walks around with that lasso of truth
keep that thing away from ya can see why
you might have a problem with that yeah
and you know what else I don't like
San Diego oh my god this time of the
year the entire town smells like Jabba
the Hutt died inside of a fish doctor
[Laughter]
[Music]
boom are you on that was a good one wait
wait wait if you hate it so much
it's idiot why'd you come back well my
son wanted to check out comic-con for
his 40th birthday
come on that captain make American
Junior
[Music]
look at him now that is a high quality
person he looks tremendous
Junior junior junior
[Applause]
are you enjoying comic-con captain make
America great again jr. you enjoying it
oh yeah this morning I went to a private
panel in room 823 at the Downtown Westin
okay I'm sorry that's a confusing a
private panel in a hotel room yes it was
just me and Captain Russia vodka man and
Anna Kournikova I told you to stay in
the car you idiot
Conan we've got to go well thank you
very much for stopping in you guys
really lifted we are leaving
San Diego just like the Chargers hail
Hydra
[Music]
you really want to bunch that Sun don't
ya
you